right now I turn to my right and
welcoming a guest who has a fantastic
podcast that's out right now thirty four
thirty podcasts and the undefeated
present the sterling Affairs that just
went live on Tuesday reported and hosted
all five episodes by ESPN senior writer
Ramona Shelburne good to see you are you
doing I'm great great stuff here Ramona
I mean so first off the Donald sterling
Affairs that we're talking about right
here I mean great name plural it cuts so
many different ways here the the
recordings between him and I guess V's
stiviano okay people remember her with
the visor with the visor that's the V
right in a way his mistress that caused
all sorts of mayhem
is the only word for it I guess so where
did a lot of these recordings that have
never been heard from before where did
you get these so you know they're a lot
of people just remember like the one
tape right where he says all the racist
things and it's terribly heard on TMZ
and the Deadspin then all over there
were actually hundreds and hundreds of
tapes that she had been making of Donald
for about some September till about
April in these break right so that's
seven months she'd been recording him
for a long time and under the auspices
of Donald had been forgetting things and
he would tell her to do things and so
she said I'm gonna record you so you
remember you telling me this mhm okay
but in the the reason why this escalates
into a full-fledged scandal is because
when she when V stiviano gets into a
sort of a domestic dispute with Shelly
sterling Donald's wife Shelley then sues
visa V on Oh to get back all of the
gifts that Donald had given her so
that's Bentley's Range Rovers Ferraris
one point eight million dollar duplex
and that court case puts the the
mistress V stiviano in a bad position
she tried unsuccessfully for months to
get Shelly sterling to drop the court
case and Shelly wouldn't drop it because
this is a principal thing here this
isn't just this is you know yes she's
mad at her husband but she's really mad
at this mistress she wants this
community
property back and those tapes get
entered into evidence in the court case
and rather than envy has to turn them
over and she this is one of them one or
two of them leak right I have a sense of
how that happens but those tapes are now
in evidence and in the court case which
I didn't think Shelley was gonna win
when that first came up I was like you
know this was a pretty landmark judgment
for Shelley - for the wife to sue the
mistress and then recover the assets as
community property she wanted though
because she listened to hundreds and
hundreds of hours of those tapes
and caught V stiviano and Donald
sterling conspiring to hide some of the
gifts that he had given her and hide
them from Shelley so that's how
everything became unraveled not only in
the marriage but also of the affair and
then eventually the Los Angeles Clippers
so and a couple other items that are
that that this podcast revealed that
Chris Brockman and I we were talking
about
you couldn't amaze I mean you couldn't
you you couldn't believe that the Lakers
essentially wound up with the bus family
because yeah because Jerry bus it needed
some money and went to Donald sterling
to get the cash and he buddy Donald
wanted real estate instead and that's
how the Lakers wound up with the bus
fare so Jerry Buss was wanting to buy
the Lakers for quite some time member
jack kent cooke was the previous owner
raj he ends up getting divorced and they
have to divide up the assets because
that's what you do in California's
community property so he has to you
didn't want to sell the team everybody
wants to own the Lakers but Jerry Buss
saw an opportunity knowing that jack
kent cooke was gonna have to sell and he
got into this very complicated
transaction that was not just like money
for the team it was a bunch of real
estate changing hands he buys the LA
Kings he buys the Lakers he buys the
forum there's a ranch up in Fort Tejon
that he also buys but at the end one of
Jerry's minority investors like drops
out some of the financing that he had to
pay jack kent cooke for all this for
this purchase was 67 million dollars
falls through at the last minute so one
of his late-night phone calls of like
trying to salvage the deal and come up
with the money so they can close was to
a guy named Donald sterling
who was a mutual who had a mutual friend
named Frank Mariani who is one of the
visionary buses business partners
they're both just real estate guys in LA
and about 11 o'clock at night they calls
Gerry he calls up Donald sterling the
next morning they go to the bank
together and Donald Sterling's oh and
Jerry Buss or not morning guys but they
had to get up and close the sale I mean
about good morning go to the bank
together to get the last three million
dollars so and then and then using
Donald Sterling's money the lakers
kicked the Clippers ass for three
decades pretty much in a way I mean
Donald certainly could have just bought
in and been one of the co-owners of the
Lakers but he didn't want that he wanted
real estate he wanted some of Jerry
busses apartment buildings have been
Santa Monica so but he did get the perks
of you know friend of the family friend
of the organization in that first year
Jerry Buss buys the team and they are
wildly successful as you know the Lakers
go on with a championship the forum club
is the West Coast version of studio 54
everybody in LA wanted to be there and
one of the frequent visitors to the
forum Club and that the special room
inside the forum Club which is that was
Jerry's room then it was like invite
only and you had to be on a list to get
in there was Donald sterling and he saw
all of that and I remember the thing
that really got me of like why this was
so important was I was talking to Bob
Steiner who was Jerry Buss his longtime
publicist and I said you know what was
Donald like in those days and he goes he
came to me one time and said I want you
to do for Donald sterling came to him
and said I want you to do for me what
you did for Jerry Buss it was it wasn't
me I can't do that you'd have to buy the
Lakers well a couple years later Donald
sterling buys the Clippers in San Diego
in San Diego and moves them to Los
Angeles and a lot of this rich comes
back to just being they are remarkably
similar backstories they're both like
rags to riches stories they both came
from poverty Donald sterling is a guy
from East LA who put himself through law
school worked his way up built a real
estate empire in LA Jerry Buss is from
Wyoming put himself through USC got a
doctorate in chemistry built a real
estate empire in LA they're very similar
back stories well you want to talk about
similar Baxter
an L a story so you're saying bus using
Sterling's money buys a team in the
Lakers that's available because jack
kent cooke is getting divorced
yeah and currently Ballmer owns the
Clippers because of a crumbling marriage
as well that's a Los Angeles story more
than anything on this for like the last
five years I've said so many times like
you could not write this like if you
wrote this as a screenplay people
wouldn't believe you like you couldn't
the twists and turns that it goes
through it is the it's really the
ultimate LA story I mean it's a but in a
lot of ways Donald sterling is a lot of
like a lot of people who come to Los
Angeles they want to be famous they
equate they equate celebrity and money
with validation and respect and I think
it you know this town chews up and spits
out a lot of people like that right you
come here thinking like you're famous
and you made it and at the end of it you
really only are you only make it for
what you're remembered by and you know
he's remembered as one of the worst
owners and all the sports I don't
Ramona Shelburne here in the Rochester
Show I don't think one of he is the
worst owner in all the sports Donald
sterling I mean in terms of win/loss in
terms of what he did while he was here
and then what he did to lose the
franchise I can't imagine a worse owner
what did you learn that you did not know
from all of the reporting in this five
again it's a five episode series that is
already live it's went live Tuesday
thirty four thirty and undefeated
present the podcast the story bin jabal
right like if you start listening to
it's like it's one of those like
serialized they sure if you start
driving LA and then end up and in Vegas
cuz you can't you know listen all five
it's I don't blame me feel okay that's
great okay sure via I think the thing
that I learned most of all was how much
this had played out over and over and
over this exact set of circumstances had
played out but we didn't have cell phone
justice we didn't have TMZ we didn't
have all the ways that rich powerful
white men get brought down now and you
know there was other mistresses there
were other scandals there were other
things that could have brought Donald
sterling down and when I'm when I was
doing this story the my North Star of
like why is this something that we're
retelling is why was it
scandal why was it this mistress why was
it this tape and why was the NBA finally
ready to do something about Donald
sterling and why and I think that what I
learned in reporting it is it took this
particular set of events this this
particular mistress this the fact that
she was able to tape him and there are
other mistresses but they couldn't they
didn't have a cell phone they would had
to take out a video camera and he would
have known what that was for and he
wouldn't have allowed that I don't know
that um a regular mainstream media I
would have just run that salacious tape
it might have taken to TMZ to do that
like I took I talked to the man from TMZ
Mike Walters who who broke the story he
didn't even know who Donald sterling was
he just knew he was a rich powerful guy
who was saying awful things and they had
to be heard so then he went to like look
up who Donald sterling was and he was
like oh yeah okay but like this was this
year I mean this is before this is right
before Ray Rice this is right this is
well before me too this is well before a
lot of the other scandals that we've
seen where rich powerful guys have been
taken down and I don't think Donald
sterling ever really saw the threat in
this until it was far too late Ramona
Shelburne here on the Rich Eisen show
another reason to retell this story
right now I mean we on this show when
Paul George decided to bust out of
Oklahoma City is he however he could to
join Kawhi Leonard here - for the for
the Clippers we said it started with V
stiviano I mean and and and I was kind
of tongue-in-cheek but not really not
really because now here we are in Los
Angeles the Lakers have yet another
generation Lee brilliant talented person
may be the most famous athlete on the
planet all due respect to soccer players
in LeBron James yeah with Anthony Davis
here Lakers have the usual but now the
unusual is that the Clippers have theirs
with Ballmer and Doc Rivers who you
interviewed in this as well because he
was the coach the time of all this this
is an interesting time to tell it
because this is the center of the NBA it
really is and like you know Ralph Lawler
who is their longtime announcer and I
did a really long interview and I you
know Ralph's Ralph just retired and he's
like oh my god really
I retired now bingo right I know and you
know there's a part of him that's like
maybe this was one year too early I
don't know but uh you know he said he
had a he had a friend who would always
say to him like you know the Clippers
are never gonna win and tell Donald
sterling it's gone I can't win with him
as the owner and Ralph was like no no
and and you know the irony of that team
and that season when the tapes come out
is like that's probably the best chance
they ever had at winning and then of
course Donald you know messes it all up
but when you look at this now it's like
they're finally dug out from that era
they finally have been able to make it
their own
and there's not really the DNA of Donald
sterling on this franchise anymore and I
think if you look at the just player MIT
player empowerment angle of this it's
it's it is quite a quite a wonderful
circle right
I mean players used to like leave the
Clippers as soon as humanly possible
free agents would leave and he Donald
sterling would just let them go cuz he
didn't believe in paying players and he
didn't believe players were valuable now
you have players like Kawhi Leonard and
Paul George asking for trades and coming
to the Clippers as free agents or in a
trade trying to get to this franchise I
mean it's the exact opposite of what
used to happen for the Clippers and it's
like it's fascinating to see what
happens next it is so fascinating you
talking a Laker fans about it because I
know because there's there's a sense of
excitement for their own world for great
reasons certainly when they were the
so-called dumpster fire three months ago
two months ago before all this happened
and did to see how a clipper nation many
are being accused of being Fairweather
frontrunner but I know a ton of clipper
fans who have just been eyeing ya on the
vine so excited right now at bomber I
mean he's a special brand of nuts but I
went to that press conference where they
introduced Paul George and Corey Leonard
and I was sitting about like six rows
back and like he got to the microphone
and I was like whew we don't need a mic
got that already right here Mike you got
you got the we we
we've cut them up and we've had a we've
had a great time with this one the
entire time you have it over there Mike
Yes No No maybe okay whatever yeah there
he is he's pumped it's all about it's
all about the Larry Obi right yeah he's
so fired up and like I you know I have
this like fun feeling with the you know
with the Clippers right now because
they're as much as they have this team
that's like incredibly deep and talented
like I don't think that they have as
much pressure on them as the Lakers
because they're not the Lakers there's
not the Lakers and they don't have
LeBron but when you look at you know
where basketball in LA sits like people
always said why did it take so long to
get rid of Donald sterling why did it
take the league you know for this tape
and for everything and you know the
cynic in me says yeah people may have
wanted Donald sterling gone but they
also didn't mind that the Clippers were
a sleeping giant and we're never gonna
be good as long as Donald sterling on
them because she's competition like
there was 29 other owners that are like
yeah that team should be really good
there in LA why do I think Ramona as we
wrap up this conversation about LA
basketball that Kobe still looms over
everything is that is that a legitimate
said to basketball fans in Los Angeles
who is the king of LA basketball I would
say 80% of them if not more would still
say Kobe Bryant given the choice of
LeBron and Kawhi and look LeBron hasn't
done anything in LA yet he hasn't I mean
he came here but didn't make an impact
in the year one and I think the enduring
image of him in year one is probably him
walking into Staples Center drinking the
wine I mean I you know I like it was a
really bad year for the Lakers and for
LeBron and so like he has to win and I
think the fact that you haven't heard
much from him this summer outside of
Taco Tuesdays I think that's a good sign
because I think he knows it and I think
that when you're quiet that means that
it's it's your brew time you know you're
yelling something up no I think he kind
of in enjoyed not the right word because
he is a competitor at the end at the
core I think the April May and June off
was refreshing to him to say that yeah
that the grind wasn't there he didn't
miss it but I think he realized that
there was something about and he don't
you feel like that when you have a big
project right and you go deep into
something and you put everything into it
and then it's over there's a sense of
like fatigue and needing to like let
yourself fill back up with motivation
and energy to take on something big
again like the man literally went to
eight straight finals that's like
putting yourself into into the going
deep for eight straight years and never
really having much downtime to recover
he finally did and now let's see how he
plays with that chip on his shoulder
with that renewed motivation to redeem
himself and remind people he's still
King James the question will be will his
body go along with it mm-hmm I guess
last one for you Ramona before I let you
go is is the best team in the West here
in Los Angeles yeah I mean the Rockets
with with I love that mix I do I really
like that ha has made itself better
Denver is basically running it back and
they were the two seed I understand
Golden State is yeah I'm one of those
Warriors believers like I still think
that I wouldn't be surprised at all if
they're near the top of the West and in
the Western Conference Finals again
here's their here's the painting I paint
for Los Angeles fans on this show
and by the way we'd even mentioned
Portland either who I which I love okay
is that Lakers clippers they're all
excited let's just say each of them wins
55 right let's just put it out there 55
yeah while the Warriors - clearly Durant
used to know clay yeah on occasion we
know curry will be out on just for a few
games whatever dream on Mike as well
Curry's trying to get the mix together
but they cobble together 48 wins
47 maybe 50 mm-hmm
they're the sixth seed Oh for a three
seeded clave clippers or Lakers team how
does that taste
right I mean like you could literally
mean the Warriors are like the team no
one's gonna want to play a bit but
remember this they're going into that
new building in San Francisco this is
this would be a natural
like sabbatical year where they've been
to five straight finals they need to the
clay is injured like let's not push it
but you can't do that moving into that
new building in that new in that rebrand
with these guys who are a little stung
that Kevin Durant left they've got
something to prove but they didn't
this wasn't just that they won without
him right and they can win without him
again so I don't see the drop-off for
the Warriors I don't and I still think
anybody who writes them off is at their
own peril yeah I don't think that the
league does either 34:30 podcasts from
ESPN and the undefeated present the
sterling Affairs you can get it right
now five episodes series where all the
ESPN app and we're all podcasts are
available reported and hosted by ESPN
senior writer Ramona Shelburne thanks
for coming in Ramona this place so well
you come here anytime you wish
Ramona Shelburne ah again check out the
podcast it is addictive be careful get
some time make sure you got some time
for yourself for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 under
red TV for free on BR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app